As a seasoned mother of four children,
let me put you on.
I keep these everywhere. In my car,
in my house, in my kids rooms,
in their bedroom. You don't know what it is?
Let me tell you. It's called the Fucking Amethyst Bag.
They usually come in packs of like 24.
You can puke in this and then you twist it,
and then it's got these little notches.
You can put it in the little notch and I'll throw it away.
So when your kid is puking,
they start puking in the car,
they start. I keep this in their bed.
So if my little kids start puking in the middle of the night
and they can't make it out of their bunk bed,
they can just puke in here.
And I don't got a deal with the fucking mess.
Or at least it minimizes it greatly.
I know we're trying to reduce plastics,
but this one is a fucking lifesaver.